hey 42 here
back in the early 1900s if you were an
affluent american who suffered from poor
health you may have considered a short
stay at battle creek sanitarium the san
as it was often called was a
world-renowned health complex that
sprawled across 30 acres of land in
michigan its pamphlet promised a cool
and delightful summer resting place and
it wasn't wrong as guests entered the
gates they were greeted with the words
men sana
incorporasano meaning a healthy mind in
a healthy body they'd see people
sunbathing in the gardens or enjoying a
stroll through the picturesque woods and
stepping into the lobby they'd be
welcomed with fine furniture crystal
chandeliers and plush persian rugs
they might also hear the occasional
scream from a remote treatment room but
we'll get to that later the san was the
go-to destination for the
health-conscious elite
wandering for its vast hallways you
could bump into the likes of henry ford
president warren harding or thomas
edison you might even see a peculiar
looking man cycling around in a white
suit and white shoes with a white
cockatoo perched on his shoulder
dictating notes to a man scurrying
behind him that man would be dr john
harvey kellogg the founder of battle
creek sanitarium and the poor fellow
behind him his younger brother william
kellogg
john kellogg was a celebrated health
gory a highly eccentric individual who
made it his life's mission to improve
america's mind body and soul he arguably
created the whole concept of wellness
you know the industry all the crazies
hang out in and thanks to his unwavering
passion for good health we now have the
delicious easy to prepare breakfast
cereal known as kellogg's cornflakes now
i'm sure you've heard john harvey
kellogg's name crop up plenty of times
before and you may have even heard that
he invented kellogg's cornflakes to stop
people from masturbating
which i'm delighted to tell you is
entirely true but what you might not
know is that this isn't even close to
the weirdest fact about john's life and
his personality far far from it as we're
about to find out john kellogg makes
gwyneth paltrow seem sane
john's dedication to health isn't
surprising not only was he a sickly
child himself but out of his 16 siblings
and half siblings six died from
infectious diseases and unfortunately
for the ones who did manage to stay
alive their parents didn't bother to
give them an education you see they were
seventh-day adventists so they didn't
really see the point when the second
coming of christ was just around the
corner
presumably jesus didn't care too much
about good grades when rewarding the
faithful but despite this setback john
was bright determined and an avid reader
and so he used any books he could get
his hands on to educate himself seeing
his potential the church supported him
from medical school and upon graduation
placed him at the head of their health
reform institute under john's leadership
it was renamed as the battle creek
medical surgical sanitarium really trips
off the tongue that one doesn't it and
he grew it rapidly into a combined
medical center spa and grand hotel
the sanitarium allowed john to practice
what he called biological living which
was heavily inspired by his adventist
beliefs essentially he saw the body as
the temple of the holy spirit something
that should be nurtured and protected at
all costs and enforced this at the sun
with messianic zeal
exercise was strongly encouraged as was
fresh air plenty of sleep good hygiene
and nutritious easy to digest food when
it came to illness many of his
treatments were grounded in dietary
restrictions he instructed guests to
avoid meat alcohol tobacco sugar and
caffeine
basically all the fun stuff most of
these treatments seem to make sense
caffeine nicotine and alcohol are
addictive drugs after all
but other practices at the sun were
a little less conventional to begin with
john was a firm believer in the methods
of horace fletcher also known as the
great masticator
fletcher was an influential health
fadist who argued that food should be
chewed and chewed until liquefied before
swallowing
john took fletcher's advice very
seriously and encouraged all his guests
to chew their food a jaw-wrenching 40
times before swallowing he even
performed renditions of a cheering song
to motivate them
culminating in the resonating chorus
choo choo choo that is the thing to do
clearly his talents were wasted in
medicine
when he wasn't serenading his guests in
the canteen whilst they furiously
masticated
john could be found experimenting with
the healing effects of artificial light
a practice that no doubt pleased thomas
edison during his visits patients will
be asked to lie down or stand up in a
shower of artificial light kind of like
a modern day sunbed and it was supposed
to cure anything from depression to
diabetes
funny how all these revolutionary health
fads just cure anything
after their light bath guests could
continue their cleanse with an enema for
those of you fortunate few who are
unfamiliar with the exhilarating world
of enemas
it involves shoving a tube up your arse
then pumping salt water into your bowels
in an attempt to give your insides a for
a cleaning out why the hell would anyone
want to do that i hear you ask well some
people believe enemas can cure
constipation certain celebs claim they
can detoxify your intestinal tract and
that they're a surefire way to instantly
lose weight but celebrities also believe
that living off cucumber juice
constitutes a healthy balanced diet so
we probably shouldn't listen to anything
they say ever but john being the
innovative thinker that he was decided
to take things one step further he
created
special machines that could pump an eye
watering
14 liters of water per minute into the
patient's bowels
then he advanced onto giving his
patients especially the most bunked up
yoghurt enemas i'm not joking
they were instructed to eat half a pint
of yogurt and then the other half
yep you guessed it right up the bum hole
john believed it would provide his
guests with protective germs and a
squeaky clean intestine
when john wasn't pumping muller into
people's he was strapping them
into the vibrating chair he'd invented
unlike today's chairs which tend to
offer a range of massage programs plush
padding and 3d surround sound
john's was a little more
rustic
it had a plain wooden seat which would
violently shake you up to 60 times a
second and for anyone who desired
something a little more hardcore you
could add a slapping machine to the
experience which would give you the
option of being flogged or pounded
if all this vibrating pounding and
flogging is getting you all excited then
i'm afraid you're out of luck because
the single most abhorrent sin you could
commit at battle creek sanitarium
was fornication
john believed that any sex outside of
procreation was against nature and the
root cause of all society's troubles
yeah this is coming from the guy who
invented a chair that vibrates and flogs
you and enjoyed stuffing yogurt into
people's bums but believe it or not he
practiced what he preached he was
celibates during his four decades of
marriage
and rather than spending his honeymoon
between the sheets with his new bride
he used that time to write about the
ills of copulation for his new book
plain facts about sexual life
lucky mrs kellock
it wasn't just sex that john loved he
viewed flirts as lecherous villains who
ought to be punished in a purgatory
seven times hotter than hell and
believed that true chastity required
purity of thought as for masturbation he
believed it was a violation of natural
law that caused a whole range of
maladies from memory loss and impaired
vision to epilepsy and even insanity
tragic news for most of his guests no
doubt but to free them from the vile
practice john offered a selection of
treatments
to begin with he would simply tie their
hands up when they were alone failing
that he would bandage their penis up or
place a cage over it if penis prison
wasn't a strong enough deterrent then dr
kellogg was a firm advocate of
circumcision performing the procedure
upon himself when he was 37 years old he
believed it was most effective at
stemming masturbation if performed
without anesthetic because it created a
salutary effect upon the mind in other
words it made the patients associate
touching his penis with absolute pain
and if circumcision didn't work he would
sew the patient's remaining foreskin
over the tip of the penis with a needle
and then twist it to a close with a
metal wire this barbaric procedure
apparently made erections impossible
bear in mind that most of his
masturbation prevention subjects were
young boys
and it reveals the sobering reality that
the man who invented your breakfast
cereal was one of america's most
prolific child abusers girls didn't get
off lightly either
john would apply pure carbolic acid to
the clitoris
or if that failed surgically remove it
but as with any illness prevention is
better than cure and john believed that
the best way to prevent sexual
stimulation in the first place was to
endure a bland diet you see whilst he
was growing up most of america's
breakfast food was fussy and stodgy
things like porridge fried bacon and hot
beef steak were all the norm so john
decided to create a breakfast food that
was easier to chew easier to digest and
bland enough to subdue any hedonistic
impulses john's puritan mandate gave
rise to the now ubiquitous cereal
kellogg's cornflakes but its creation
also heavily involves his little brother
will it's fair to say that john and will
had a complicated relationship
growing up john pushed him around and
even whipped him despite will being
eight years his junior if it was a
particularly cold winter's night he
would use will's back as a foot warmer
real likeable character this jungle
isn't he
as adults and after john had established
a sanitarium he invited will to work
there but their relationship didn't
improve
will often worked up to 120 hours a week
for very little pay and his duties
included keeping john's books
shaving him and even taking his notes
for him when he went to the bathroom
when he wasn't satisfying john's every
whim will would help out in the
sanitarium's kitchen by 1877 john had
invented a kind of breakfast biscuit for
his guests it was a mixture of flour
oats and cornmeal which he baked twice
at a very high temperature to make it
easier to digest
the biscuit which was blander than a
cold plate album and harder than a rock
caused one guest to break her tooth so
from that point on john would smash it
into little pieces creating a kind of
granola
then one night in 1898 will accidentally
left out a batch of dough when he
returned to it the next morning it had
fermented he decided to throw course
into the wind and roll it out anyway
and when he did the bacteria-infused
dough
produced perfectly thin flakes that
became crispier and tastier once baked
it was the world's first flaked cereal
will carried on experimenting with his
new recipe and after replacing the wheat
with corn he produced flakes which were
even crunchier the cereal was an instant
hit first with patients at the sun and
then with the wider public once it was
advertised in newspapers and on
billboards
now john couldn't care for profit his
only concern was abolishing masturbation
and healing the world
one bowl at a time but will was a
natural-born businessman and knew their
cereal would be more competitive if they
added sugar to the flakes unsurprisingly
john wasn't on board fearing the sweet
taste would cause anyone who ate it to
instantly and uncontrollably fondle
themselves and so he forbade his brother
from doing anything of the sort
so will finally tired of living under
his big brother's shadow struck out on
his own he bought the rights to
manufacture cornflakes and founded the
battle creek toasted cornflake company
in 1906. his cereals were an enormous
success and three years later he was
producing 120 000
boxes of cornflakes every day
will's advertising tactics were as
creative as his brother's health
treatments
only far less psychotic his company was
the first to include a toy inside the
box and one of the first to include
nutrition labels on the box one
particularly successful campaign told
readers to wink it your grocer and see
what you get a risky strategy perhaps
and one that would have offended his
prudish brother but those who followed
this curious instruction received a free
sample of cornflakes and hence the brand
experienced a rapid boost in sales
sadly john was less than enthusiastic
about his little brother's success he
insisted on using the kellogg name for
the sanitarium's own healthier cereals
and will who believed that a tasteless
kellogg cereal would harm his own brand
and company
sued him john sued him back and the two
fought a vicious legal battle for the
best part of a decade the question at
the heart of it all was
who was the real kellogg john naturally
believed that he was after all he was
the first of the two to make it big and
arguably the most famous doctor in
america whose books had been translated
into several languages but thanks to
will's sizable investment into
advertising kellogg was now a household
name and more or less synonymous with
cornflakes eventually will succeeded and
in 1922 he was finally able to establish
the kellogg's cereal company to
celebrate he introduced the famous
rooster mascot for his cereal which came
about because he realized the welsh word
for rooster
keliogh sounds a little like kellogg
cereal was a complete game changer gone
were the days of getting up early to
start the fire just to make porridge or
reheating last night's greasy leftovers
cornflakes were a convenient nutritious
ready-to-eat breakfast
perfect for the busy masses who'd left
the farms to work as employees in
factories following the industrial
revolution kellogg's cereal company led
the pack in what became a multi-million
dollar industry john meanwhile was
forced to pay the costs of the legal
battle he faded into obscurity and lost
much of his credibility the number of
visitors at the sun dropped dramatically
during the great depression and by 1938
he closed its doors forever
left with three million dollars in debt
he developed bronchitis four years later
and died of pneumonia at the age of 91.
although the two brothers hadn't spoken
properly in years
john did write a reconciliatory letter
to will the exact wording of the seven
page document is unknown
but the gist of it was probably i was a
bit of a dick
maybe i shouldn't have been such a
detestable monster sorry bro
regrettably john's secretary decided
that it was beneath her employer to send
such a letter to his nemesis and so she
decided to stash it in her desk will
didn't see it until he himself was on
his deathbed at which point he
reportedly sat up in bed and declared my
goodness why didn't someone tell me
before this
they may have been enemies until the
bitter end and sure one of them was the
quackiest quack who ever quacked
but together
they changed the breakfast table forever
thanks for
watching check out my new podcast random
interesting facts available on youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts link in the
description below thanks